vladimir achète une cuisinière 9 à la
livraison
il constate que la porte est égratigné
que faire selon la loi un bien livré
doivent être conformes à ce qui a été
acheté cela dit mir pourrait donc
refuser la livraison parce que ce qu'il
a acheté petite cuisinière en parfait
état mais il a besoin de sa nouvelle
cuisinière maintenant alors il peut la
garder et prendre une photo
notez le problème sur la facture et
faire signer le livreur puis en envoyer
une copie aux commerçants le commerçant
peut alors proposer à vladimir de
réparer remplacer rembourser et
reprendre la cuisinière ou encore lui
offrir une réduction de prix et 10
civils a dit mir ne réussit pas à
s'entendre avec le vendeur il devra
intenté une action devant le tribunal le
fin mot de l'histoire
après une livraison si vous avez une
déception vous avez plusieurs options